so bc canada toronto
toronto toronto toronto toronto thailand
toronto yes you're one of us
yes i am i love that
okay perfect um you know you've been a
part of so many iconic projects but what
has the experience of the mandalorian
meant to you not only in front of the
camera but of course behind the camera
as well
well man
the first time i saw the star wars the
original
was a billion years ago in san francisco
down by the pier the theater standing
waiting in line with all those other
people for about 45 minutes to an hour i
remember it
and then seeing
i mean we're talking maybe 45 years ago
something like that right
and here we are
and i'm a part of it
that's a little wild
i mean no that's 50 something years ago
that's almost that's almost 50 years ago
so
so how is it
it's bizarre is the best word for it and
and the reason it's bizarre is
people
still love this
i mean it's like
and maybe love it even more we have we
have fans
for the mandalorian
who are
tiny children
to grandmas and grandpas
and i know because i meet a lot of them
right
i mean
i don't think look george is brilliant
george is a genius george created
something that is truly people throw the
word around iconic but truly iconic and
all over the world but nobody could have
ever thought george included that all
these years later
this thing is like its own world its own
galaxy that is such a good way of
putting it and there's such a fierce
protectiveness that we have as fans over
groku over baby yoda like we can't
handle if baby yoda's in trouble i know
oh no guess what
we're that way in the show as well
you know
you feel
i mean
it's bizarre to be
to feel that way about an inanimate
object who comes to life when the
cameras start rolling
and we're all kind of clamoring to be
next to baby yoda you call him i call
him grogu because that's his real name
stop calling him baby yoda
i do too sometimes i must admit
i can't help it i know i know but you
know
it's again it's just bizarre that's all
i can come up with thank god
john favreau
was touched by something that caused him
to create this because we wouldn't have
this conversation if it weren't for that
i know you can't say much for the next
season is there a word is there a word
is there a word you can give us or tease
us to explain the season yes
exciting
carl i'm gonna take that okay
thank you so much
you